what I'm doing here is I'm getting
myself in front of these people with a
different conversation that they may be
having with all the other hundreds of
recruiters are calling them or sending
them messages or emails I'm
differentiating myself to get myself in
front of them and open up that
conversation I'm going to be genuinely
sharing information with them and not
expect anything in return right now but
what I have done is I've shown them I'm
credible I've shown them who I am as a
person as well it's a people game you've
got to put yourself out there put
yourself in front of people and if I can
show these clients that I'm credible I
know what I'm talking about and I'm
actually a pretty decent person he's a
human being and I can deliver for them
why wouldn't they use me